I am not abdicating because the position was too hard on me,...
...but because of my belief that the responsibility of this country...
...has to be in the hands of a new generation.
With complete trust, I will transfer the throne to my son, the Prince of Orange.
He and Princess Maxima are fully prepared for their future task.
Queen Beatrix of the Netherlands has abdicated in favor of her son,...
...Prince Willem-Alexander, age 45.
The Dutch Prime Minister made a statement shortly after the queen's announcement.
On this special moment for the queen and for the Netherlands,...
...I want to give my respect and admiration for her outstanding services...
...both in and for our country.
From the moment she was crowned in 1980, she has given her heart and soul.
Beatrix assumed the throne after her mother, Queen Juliana,...
...stepped aside in her favor 33 years ago.